y vamos hasta puerto príncipe capital de
haití para hablar con el periodista y
analista gotson pierre bigotón buenos
días como amanece el país y cómo van las
tareas de rescate de quienes permanecen
bajo los escombros
buenos días siempre una angustia de este
balance que aumenta cada hora empieza
con lo como lo estamos yendo a llegar la
ayuda externa en algunos sitios pero
ahora es como una gota de agua en el
océano pequeños equipos de bomberos
haitianos están allá también personal de
ambulancias equipos aéreas de eeuu
empiezan a ayudar a los médicos a
transportar a pacientes gravemente
heridos de las zonas afectadas hasta la
capital en servicios médicos de
emergencia dicen que trabajando en
coordinación con las autoridades locales
y otros socios sigue siendo
espera en varias ciudades
pequeñas como caballo como bajar el
extremo sur oeste y también varias
llamadas para no olvidar pequeñas
ciudades
qué planes está llevando a cabo el
gobierno para enfrentar esta tragedia
estaba preparado qué es lo que dice la
ciudadanía y le pido que nos
contextualice porque además del altísimo
peligro que hay en este momento de
infecciones por la tragedia pues también
están los contagios de kobe 19 con los
que tienen que lidiar los médicos es un
problema porque es lo que critica la
sociedad civil que no hay un perdón
estatal como tal para hacer frente a la
situación lamenta que a partir de una
medida de estado de emergencia no se
hayan anuncios
de medidas concretas y la sociedad civil
dice también que va a organizar la
vigilancia sobre la distribución de la
ayuda para asegurar que llegue a las
personas que están
en la necesidad de
verdaderamente de esta ayuda
y muy rápidamente para darle un ejemplo
el papá francisco hizo un llamado de la
solidaridad y distintos países han
empezado a enviar ayudas como está
haciendo la cooperación internacional
bueno se espera mucho de la cooperación
internacional hay anuncios de españa de
latinoamérica de cuba que está ya con
sus médicos y de la república dominicana
esperamos mucho de la comunidad
internacional pero empezó desde el
fenómeno el el inicio del fenómeno una
solidaridad local que hace que ahora
personales profesionales
vecinos están movilizados para dar vida
a algunas víctimas